In this section, we will be making minor changes to the metahuman neutral pose by adjusting
vertex positions using the Propagate changes from Scene to DNA script.
We will first assemble the scene for this specific scenario using the DNA viewer run
in Maya script.
Then we will save the current vertex and joint positions, adjust the mesh vertex positions,
and then save those changes to the DNA file.
Let's return to Maya and go through this workflow.
Back inside of Maya, in a new python window, I have added the Propagate changes script
with the correct input for the files and paths.
To use this script to edit the neutral pose, first we will need to assemble the scene using
the DNA viewer run in Maya script.
I have the DNA viewer run in Maya script over here in this window.
I'm going to select all of this and then right click and select execute.
In the DNA viewer window, I'm going to select the path of the DNA file.
I will go to the DNA calibration folder and then open up the data folder and then open
up the DNA files folder.
I will select the DNA file named lina and then select open.
Now I will select load DNA.
Next, I want to assemble all of the LODs and their contents, so I will choose select all
meshes.
For the build options, we will only need to load the joints for this scenario.
Now we can select process and I will select discard any changes for this scene.
Now that this is assembled, I can minimize this window and go to the top view.
We can see that everything we chose to be assembled has been loaded into this Maya scene.
Down here in the bottom right in the display panel, since I do not need all of the lower
LODs visible, I will hide everything except for LOD 0.
Now the first step of this script is to save the current affairs.
To do this, in the script editor, I will switch over to the Python window with the
Propagate Changes script.
In the Outliner, I will select the head group.
Then in the script editor, I will scroll past all of this code.
We have already changed the input for these paths.
I am going to go all the way down to the end of sub-step 3 where it says loaded data end
of third step.
I am going to select all of this and go all the way to the top and now I will right click
and select execute.
Once this process is complete, as a best practice, I am going to save this Maya scene by going
to File, Save Scene As and since I have already gone through this process, I will select the
Save Current Affairs scene and overwrite it.
Now before we move on, let's do a quick review of the steps we just went through.
We begin this workflow by first assembling the scene using the DNA viewer run in Maya
script.
First, we will load the DNA file located in the DNA files folder.
Next, we want all of the LODs and their contents so we will click on Select All Meshes.
And in the build options, we only need to load the joints and then select process.
This will assemble a new Maya scene.
Next we will want to save the current affairs.
For this step, we want to save the current vertex and joint positions of Meshes.
To do this, in the script editor, with the Python window that has the entire script pasted
in there and configured with the name of the DNA file and the paths to the root directory
and updated GUI and assembly script, we will select the head group in the outliner and
then run the entire script up to the end of step 3 which reads loaded data, end of
third step.
As a best practice, we want to save this Maya scene.
Now let's return to Maya and continue by making some adjustments to the vertex positions.
Back inside of Maya, over here in the show panel, I'm going to uncheck joints.
Now before I start moving vertex positions, let's say I want the changes that I make to
also be on LOD 1, 2 and 3.
In this case, it would be easier if I wrap those other LODs to LOD 0 first so that the
changes I make to LOD 0 will be transferred to those other LODs.
To do this, in the outliner, I'm going to collapse the geometry group.
Since I'm going to be making changes to LOD 0, 1, 2 and 3, I'm going to go here and collapse
the head LOD 0 group, the head LOD 1 group, the head LOD 2 group, and the head LOD 3 group.
To wrap these LODs to LOD 0, select the head LOD 1 mesh and then select the head LOD 0
mesh.
Go to deform and open up the wrap options to make sure everything looks okay.
And now select apply.
Repeat this for LOD 2.
Select it and then select LOD 0.
In the wrap options, select apply and repeat this one more time for LOD 3.
And then select LOD 0 and select apply.
As a best practice, I'm going to save this Maya scene by going to file, save scene as,
and overwrite the file named modify mesh since I've already gone through this workflow a few times.
Now with everything wrapped to LOD 0, we can edit the mesh.
I will select the head LOD 0 and adjust the position of the head.
I will switch from object mode to vertex.
I'm just going to select this random section of the nose region, switch over to translate,
and then simply move these vertices.
The purpose here is to show how this script can be used when we change vertex positions.
I will switch back to object mode.
Now we can see this minor adjustment to the nose area.
If I go down here to the display panel and turn off LOD 0 and turn on LOD 1,
we can see that this adjustment is there.
And it is also there for LOD 2 and LOD 3.
Since we did not wrap the other LODs, those adjustments will not be transferred to them.
I'm going to save the scene again by going to file, save scene.
Now before we move on, let's review these steps.
When making adjustments to the neutral pose by moving vertices, wrap the LODs you wish to
change to LOD 0 first so that they can all be adjusted at the same time.
To do this, select the head LOD 1 mesh and then select the head LOD 0 mesh,
go to deform and select wrap.
Repeat this for all of the head LODs you wish to make changes to.
Then edit the vertex positions of the head LOD 0 mesh and check that those changes are
visible across the LODs that were wrapped.
Now let's return to Maya and continue.
Back inside of Maya, before we run the rest of the script to save these changes to the
DNA file, we will want to delete the wrap nodes.
I will first demonstrate this by selecting the head LOD 0 mesh.
And then we'll select the first head LOD base mesh wrap node.
Then I will go to edit, select delete all by type and select history.
Now that I have demonstrated this step, I'm going to select the head LOD 0 mesh
and then select the rest of the wrap nodes and repeat this step.
I will go to edit, delete all by type and select history.
We can now delete the wrap nodes.
I will go here in the display panel and I will make LOD 1 visible just to make sure that when
I delete the wrap node, the changes I made are still there.
So with the LOD 1 wrap node selected, I will delete it.
We can see the change I made is still there.
Repeat this step for LOD 2.
Making it visible down here and then deleting the wrap node over here.
And finally repeat this for LOD 3.
Make it visible down here and then delete the wrap node over here.
I will save the scene again.
Before we move on, let's review these steps.
Before saving the changes to the DNA file, delete the wrap nodes and check that the changes
are still visible on the other LODs.
To do this, select the head LOD 0 mesh and then select all the base mesh wrap nodes.
Go to edit, delete all by type and select delete history.
Then delete each wrap node while making sure those changes are still visible
by toggling through the LODs in the display panel.
Now let's return to Maya and continue with the rest of this workflow.
Back inside of Maya, we can now save the changes that have been made to the DNA file.
I will select the head group and I will go back here to show and make the joints visible again.
With the head group selected, we will go to the script editor
and scroll all the way down here below sub-step 3.
We have completed step 4 which is to modify the rig
and now we can execute step 5 where we see propagate changes to DNA.
This portion will update the vertex and joints to their new positions
and it will save the changes to the DNA file.
This portion will assemble a new Maya scene with the updated DNA.
Select everything and execute it.
This script will create an output folder and will add the modified DNA file in there.
Once the new Maya scene has loaded, we can see our modified DNA and the changes we made.
We can go here and toggle through the LODs to make sure that the changes have been saved to the other LODs.
It is worth mentioning something about this workflow where we move the vertex positions.
I will reposition the head and I will make the joints visible over here.
The surface joints are positioned by vertices.
When pronounced changes to the vertex positions are made,
the surface joints may need to be manually repositioned.
This is because surface joints preserve the volume for lower LODs.
You can either manually reposition them or use a script to automate this process.
Now this script does not have that command.
There is a script that does.
I will search for it in the Python windows I have open.
It is this one which is the UnrealFest calibration script.
This contains commands that save the current surface joint positions as a JSON file.
All of these here are the surface joints that it loads into memory.
Once the vertex positions are moved, the surface joints will snap to the new vertex positions.
This demonstrates how you can use code from other scripts such as this one
so that you do not have to manually reposition these.
Now let's do a quick review of what we just covered.
Once you are finished making changes to the vertex positions of the neutral pose,
to save the new vertex and joint positions and update the DNA,
select the head group, and then run the rest of the lines.
And then run the rest of the script from step 5 that reads propagate changes to DNA.
This will update the joints and vertex to their new positions.
And these changes will be saved in a new DNA file in the output folder the script creates.
This will also assemble a new Maya scene so that you can inspect the updated DNA.
If changes to the vertex positions are pronounced,
the surface joints may need to be manually repositioned.
Surface joints preserve the volume for lower LODs.
The UnrealFest calibration script contains commands that save the current surface joint positions
as a JSON file.
And once changes to the vertex positions have been made,
it will snap the surface joints to the new vertex positions.
Saving you time and having to manually move them by hand.
This is a great example of how you can use code from other scripts.
Now let's move on to the next section where we go over another simple use case scenario
that uses the propagate changes from scene to DNA script
to make minor modeling changes using the joints and skin clusters.